im bett
[Musik]
hallo zusammen heute stehe ich mal mit
einem special guest vor der kamera juni
hamza
auf jeden fall waren wir heute unser
typisches klassisches ramadan reihen ein
studio auf jeden fall geht es heute
darum weil jedes jahr reden was ist
eigentlich ramadan und so bilden
natürlich keine religions- kanal wir
sind ein koch kanal aber weil man fastet
und den anfragen nicht ist braucht man
das dem fastenbrechen inspiration award
regisseur es ist tradition so und daher
habe ich mir gedacht diesmal machen wir
es anders weil ich weiß dass die kita
kunterbunt ist wir haben alle religionen
das ist auch gut so und ich möchte
einfach nur ein bisschen so die
oberflächlichen fragen beantworten damit
ihr auch nachvollziehen könnt worum geht
es im ramadan will auch instagram wird
der dann auch und ich will dass ihr
fasten und das dann sehr spät essen und
der ist pressetext was das auch ist ich
denke ich denke es auch manchmal muss es
mag ja aber es kommt doch immer neue
leute dazu beziehungsweise auch jüngere
leute die das sagen ich bin mit 12 oder
ich keine ahnung davon was ja genau ich
wusste dass gerade und man darf nicht
aber so denken wie hat man weiß alles
aber vielleicht andere wissen genau
darum geht es richtig bewusst geworden
weil wir seit august ja unsere
wundervolle und bezaubernde fahrer im
team haben und die hat schön auch so
einfach fragen auch so erzwingen dritter
haften so ähnlich muss es schon sein mit
diesem kleinen mini effekt nur zu
befragen
aber wir starten jetzt in dem sarah und
einfach die fragen die von euch rein
kamen über instagram nehmen sie uns die
stellen
natürlich auch mit parallel werden indem
ich befüllte dattel machen datteln also
dafür pralinen machen und dafür habe ich
hier schon freue mich kuvertüre fein
gehackt zwei drittel der garten
kuvertüre mäßigkeit über einem wasserbad
darfst du schon mal rühren und wenn das
geschmolzen ist kommt das letzte drittel
dazu das dient einfach dazu dass wir
spielen einen schönen glanz farben und
kein grauschleier und das ist dann halt
einfach schön temperierte provisorisch
chemie angesprochen ja manchmal ist
backen echt jimmy du darfst
kurz darauf eingehen also was ist avatar
also erst mal zu mir so ja das ist so
wie euer weihnacht
genaueres wollte sich grube ja was ist
überhaupt ramadan ramadan ist der elfte
monat der mondkalender man geht nicht
nach dem gregorianischen kalender sind
wir gehen quasi wenn es um den islam
geht nicht nach dem sonnen kalender
sondern nach dem mondkalender der hat im
schnitt 10 11 tage weniger als sehr
sonnenkalender den wir so käme hat der
365 tage und ramadan ist einfach der
elfte monat und in diesem monat passten
muslime von sonnenaufgang bis
sonnenuntergang das ist aber auch was
der spirituell ist es ist auch so dass
muslime dann in dem monat einfach mehr
so in sich kehren alte schlechte
gewohnheiten ablegen wie so eine art
reset wieso nacht neues werk ist es
schon so man sagt auch nicht nur sogar
traut kann man sogar zum ersten scheint
er erst also ersten strahlen sondern
musik dieses video ist jetzt vor gedreht
und so in zehn tagen beginnt der ramadan
endet aus den aber ich würde gerne mal
gucken ich mich dieses jahr auch gar
nicht befugt von wann bis wann fasten
fördern dieses jahr das habe ich gar
nicht durch meine mit einer bis 20 uhr
ist nicht so ihr seid etwas frühere halb
neun das dass das schlimmer ist jetzt im
alter nehme ich nur wer das schöne ist
ja das kommt jetzt eigentlich wissen sie
wo gefasst meine ich guck mal wenn wir
jetzt kosten würden alle staaten nun
fünf monate
diese messen und sein stab komme jetzt
eigentlich jetzt ist ja noch die
winterzeit nicht die zeit verschiebt
sich ja ein recht zum märz deswegen also
die
19 uhr drehen können wir sind aber jetzt
dadurch dass es am 31 märz die die
finther die sommerzeit kommen und wir
erst am 2 april statt ja aber nächstes
jahr
für zehn tage angelegt also sichert es
geht wirklich los dass man um fünf uhr
morgens wenn die sonne quasi auf geht
nichts mehr essen darf man fastet bis 20
5 aber da wir jetzt circa 29 oder 38
tage fasten am ende verschiebt sich das
so ein bisschen das heißt gaal vom
letzten tag dürfen wir um 33 morgens
nicht mehr ist man nicht mehr trinken
und um 21 uhr abends
das ist abenteuerlich dass
[Musik]
alles verschiebt sich nach hinten
stimmen ja alles wird früher also bedarf
um so früher hat nicht mehr essen und
umso später hatte ich mehr besten grau
und ihr habt ja auch diese drei festtage
also entlastet dann monat und dann du
sagst ja wie weihnachten also in hansell
beschäftigt um einen song st wir haben
ja man sagt dann natürlich viele sagen
war zugleich das ja so oder so
eingedeutscht damit eigentlich ist es
nicht das richtige wort ich weiß auch
dass die sich beschwert darüber aber man
macht es halt einfach sagen also das ist
halt jetzt mittlerweile so ist schon so
gut am pläne ab aber eigentlich heißt es
fastenbrechen fest manche sagen
ramadanfest es geht auch noch
das ist ja quasi dass das fest der bis
fast bis ins 14 heißt ja so quasi
fastenbrechen das kommt vom fk heißt ja
auch fastenbrechen die drei tage was ist
so besonders an dann sagen ach so ja ich
sag jetzt ich will sich weihnachten
vergleichen aber dass man kommt mit der
familie zusammen man scheint den kleinen
kindern was gehen meistens sagen was man
denkt mittlerweile schon recht geschenke
und gerade auf unserem der fall ist echt
schwierig geworden bei achten wir
vernichten die ich jetzt habe das ist so
schwierig geschenke so viel presse aber
dadurch dass die dann in der in der
schule zu gehen wenn alle anderen kinder
bank was aber ich sehe dass und das hab
ich zu weihnachten bekommen und ich
recht traurig sind dass man einfach kein
weihnachten feiern haben die das dafür
dann das gebrannte kind jetzt aus einem
podcast thema sein man hat ihn ganz
ehrlich was man früher bei mir der
schule also ich sage dass ich traurig
aber du bist nicht schuldige fünfte
klasse ja dachte dabei nach dem kampf
heute wieder eine schule zurück und alle
so yeah ich habe die neue schuhe shoppen
euro bekommen da ist das und er ich
werde ich sagen jetzt aber bei mir war's
also ich habe sieben geschwister habe
und deshalb bis ich wieder gewinnen ja
und die heizungen sie haben so alle so
zum kanada zum protest haben wir halt in
monopoly bekommen und würden alle
mitspielen also dass wir nicht sogar
viel sinnvoller sind ja eine sache
erfreuen hat sie gerade hier war gerade
jetzt wo ich habe das gefühl ist es wert
sich die man gegen meine geschwister
schießen aber ich habe das gefühl dass
die dass die kinder jetzt echt verwöhnt
sind ohne spaß der anfang aus anders wir
haben ja ein geschenk von gemeinsamen
hat er also wie war dein geschenk von
mir
fand ja eigentlich sehr jung mit dem
fast man also ich weiß ich kann mich nur
erinnern der grundschule da hatte ich
mal jemanden da der auch gefastet und da
unsere lehrerin so wissen zum wasser zu
trinken weil sie ein bisschen mitleid
hat war dritte klasse oder so es war ja
auch so eine frage so eben wie viel
jahren wird es so gemacht oder wird
empfohlen oder bleibt es ein bisschen
den eltern überlassen ja es hat erstens
den eltern überlassen und ich glaube
auch kein ich darf auch wenn ein
elternteil wirklichen kinder dritten
klassischer mag ich glaube es war eher
so dass er selber weil genau das einmal
mitmachen wollt weil ich muss ich auch
glaube er das kind sagt jetzt ich fasse
ich was aber zu hause ist das ja das ist
auch aber das ist aus stolz weil ich
glaube dass mal ein dritter klasse er
war schon sehr sehr müde das kann ich
mir schon vorstellen
er ist unser recht hat derweil um müde
und nicht eben jetzt unter oder also
beim es ist also meine schwester was wir
auch so die wollten den gefassten mal
sehr gefasster halbe tragbar dann gehen
die schule fasste in der schule zu sein
dann kommen wir zurück und dann hast du
halt mittag gegessen aber die wollen ja
auch mitmachen das ist ja auch etwas
schönes gefühl wenn man größere familie
ist wenn man halt so zwei drei
geschwistern aber hat die mitmachen die
älter sind das hat man auch in die nach
haben das ist unerträglich wenn wir nach
armen nicht irgendwie also ich war ja
früher auch weil ich habe ja auch fast
ja mein leben lang schafft also im
endeffekt und ich habe auch schon
teilweise mit 89 angefangen jetzt nicht
jeden tag aber ich hab's versucht weil
ich einfach wollte ich wollte einfach
dieses fähigen mit mitbekommen ja das
verstehe ich aber grundsätzlich sind
kinder vom fasten ausgenommen auch
kranke sind ausländer menschen die
medikamente brauchen die das körperlich
nicht keinen charakter genau zum
beispiel mein schwiegerpapa so haben sie
das papa fassen kann jetzt eigentlich
nicht mehr fast genau solche menschen
sind komplett ausgenommen davon auch
kinder die dann so langsam in die
pubertät kommen bei den medien ist
manhart periode bekommt oder so also
oder bei den menschen
ich kann nicht fassen
sondern weil sie diese pubertät ein und
dann könnte man quasi aber es gibt jetzt
nicht dieses bau ab dem zeitpunkt und
auf dem alter muss zu fasten sondern
wenn man hat erwachsen wie es gibt keine
dramatischen das wird jetzt auch nicht
irgendwie vorgegeben das heißt
spätestens wenn du 18 bist musst du
jeweils das ist
einfach nur quasi nachdem wie die
personen sich fühlt im endeffekt wenn
der sagt okay wir bereit dafür meistens
ist das schon so alt ich bin jetzt 14
ich fange jetzt anzufassen das ist so
dass zehn jahren ich bin 15 ich fange
jetzt an das ist meist so diesem in
diesem glücklichen alter
das war ja auch so ein bisschen so ne
frage also ihr habt ihr ja fast schon
beantwortet eben ob es auch muslime gibt
die sich nicht an die fastenzeit halten
können also die frage war er auch die
temperatur bezogen ja aber ich denke man
da eben krankheiten oder ganz ehrlich
was hier jemand der beim schweizer
arbeite und das wirklich krank reise 60
x 40 50 grad ist und daher acht stunde
ausharren musste er ist natürlich
befreit davon klar jeder muss selber
wissen aber ist natürlich mit freitag an
wird er es nicht körperlich schafft
seine arbeit nachzugehen weil er könnte
seinen job verliert ist richtig du
kannst dich deinen job ausstehenden das
ist ja nicht gleich jedes ist das fasten
das gleiche ist für fußballer fußball
nochmals ja auch so also fußball dann
fassen dann nach und nach kostenlos
bedeuteten das heißt du legst es dann
quasi nach dem ramadan nimmt für diese
tage fort und hat nicht gefastet hat das
heißt im endeffekt ich könnte sagen ich
habe letzten jahr drei täter gefasst ich
habe
dann wüsste ich dass spätestens bis kurz
vor auf oder noch also ich jetzt quasi
das ist jetzt müsse es noch nach vorn
genau und nicht danach weil dann ist es
schon die frist erloschen oder auch
frauen die dann ihre periode haben hier
fünf tage nicht fasten die sicher eine
periode hat dann darf man auch nicht was
das soll eine erleichterung sein für die
frau auch wenn jetzt eine frau sagt zum
beispiel ich habe aber gar keine
schmerzen alles cool und so du dass du
musst diese erleichterung dann auch
annehmen dass das auch im sinne der der
gesundheit quasi mann soll dann auch
viel trinken und so weiter und auch dann
diese 45 tage fast man einfach das jahr
über mal hier mal da einfach nach ihr
habt ihr auch schon mal dann tag wie ich
durchgehalten also es war ja auch so
eine frage so bzw auch wie strengen seid
ihr mit euch beim fasten als war so
dieses jetzt mal ehrlich so zieht er das
wirklich durch und eben auch habt ihr
mal täglich gemacht also wenn das thw
genommen in der periode normal ja ich
also ich hatte es ist sogar ein blog
online wo ich mal beim dekorieren einer
torte auswahl sehen so sehr abgelenkt
volle konzentration
das haben sie vergessen hat in dem
moment dass ich fast immer voll beim
element aber das bricht das fasten nicht
weil die absicht war ja nicht die sich
damit den staat zu machen sondern man
man hat das fasten dadurch nicht
gebrochen der tag zählt also noch
sozusagen und so durchziehen tu mir das
schon sagen dass der hansi mich auch
immer motiviert weil ich bin zum mensch
ist schon ein bisschen komisch jetzt
schon aber
das wird auch nicht übers herz bringen
dann die absicht zu fassen die sollte
man immer am abend davor fassen morgen
werde ich fasten einfach für sich und
die dann zu dass das verbrechen ist also
das könnte ich das muss ich selbst muss
ich da für sich entscheiden aber das
könnte ich gehe ja auch nichts wenn ich
jetzt hier vor der kamera sitze und sage
ich faste und 2 und später seht ihr im
video wo ich halte mich fast oder sogar
also das ist halt voll also ich muss
auch sagen viele wagen aufbauen so von
anstrengend sei aber wisst ihr nicht
schön das ist dass man am arm das fasten
dieses fastenbrechen dieses zusatz es
sind auch nachhaltige wirkung das muss
man auch simon ist also viele studien
belegen dass auch das dass fasten eine
heilende wirkung ja das machen auch
viele also viele vor ostern also meine
mutter macht das jetzt auch die macht
heilfasten ist man halt nur eine woche
naja und bisschen anders aber fasten ist
sondern die gesellschaft quasi so
ausgezogen effekt und dann
er hält sich nach dem fasten quasi neue
verträge ob die dann quasi gespeichert
werden und das service und habt ihr
nicht ganz klar ganz so nachvollziehen
aber sowie aber abgesehen davon reinigt
das auch körper es reinigt auch seele
muss man sagen da manchmal was für ein
schmarren manchmal tags unternehmen auch
ob ich nehme mal zu lustigerweise es ist
wirklich so man hat doch irgendwann das
ist so krass wenn ihr müsst ihr müsst
mal darauf achten immer nach der nach
der ersten woche oder gehör wird
irgendwie klar ich habe das gefühl meine
reflexe werden besser ich weiß nicht
warum ich habe dass jedes tor das ich so
merkel die sind da die verschärfung sich
irgendwann merkt auch so macht von alm
zu viert ist nicht gut und ja und wenn
man hat manchmal viel viel ist da merkt
man das ja dann macht sich das bemerkbar
meinem körper ist das dann auch soweit
hier sagte gerade sich dann immer so ein
bisschen soße reizbar also oft kam so
ein bisschen die frage auf wie es
überhaupt durchhalte dieses ist ja nicht
nur ganzen tag nichts trinkt ja auch
nichts also kein wasser kein a nix und
und geht ihr euch dann an den hals seid
ihr reizbar geht nämlich aus dem weg der
ist tage einer hat auch geschrieben wird
oft migräne am ersten tag ja das ist das
ist selbst wenn sie mit dem rauchen
aufhört hast du in den ersten paar tagen
migräne das ist ganz normal aber das
heißt wenn ich das der körper gegen die
dadurch leidet oder so also klar das ist
ganz normal dass eine umstellung ist
wenn man irgendwie elf monate lang ganz
normal alles zu sich genommen hat aber
das legt sich dann auch sofort wieder
das ist einfach eine umstellung nur
einmonatiger so wollte wie siehst du das
so kann man ist mal gereift ich merke
wenn ich richtig gerechnet bricht die
ich dir aus dem weg aber es ist nach
aber selbst so schlecht so also über ist
das bisschen gewaltgrad aber dann muss
man sich gestern wie sich ein kern so
sehen uns frieden schützen aber es
bringt nichts
und genau weiß es doch so kassner und
ist es ja auch selber ist sie auch eine
erziehung daran es soll ja nicht nur
jetzt du verzichte ich noch essen oder
trinken sondern man sollte auch quasi
auf diese also man sollte sich in der
zeit auch benehmen sollen sie für so
machen aber sollte auch in der
zeitlichen sich kennt man sagen okay ich
muss einfach ruhiger werden müsse
einfach ich darf nicht so schnell
ausrastet im endeffekt das so ist mit
der meditation ich sag immer wieder es
ist was sehr spirituell ist jeder nimmt
für sich wieder neue lehrern mit aus dem
monaten bei mir ist es auch so manchmal
wenn ich mehr gebracht muss mal wieder
runterkommen und so ich darf nicht immer
so alles so vielleicht eng stehen nicht
sehen da hat ja jeder so sind in einem
laster die luft besser freut sich auf
ist auf jeden fall noch einmal zum
aspekt nicht trinken und viele sagen das
ist doch mega ungesund es gibt studien
mittlerweile die belegen es ist nicht
ungesund im gegenteil auch oft mit dem
mit dem wasser verzicht und du nimmst ja
also am abend sollte er keine softdrinks
vielleicht regen was du trinkst ja am
abend das alles nach du nimmst du deine
eineinhalb bis zwei liter wasser zu die
in dieser zeitspanne das ist gesund für
den körper aber natürlich nicht das
ganze jahr über sondern wirklich nur
diesen monaten kaufen das bedeutet dann
ramadan feuchtmann du hast schon mal
vorweg genommen mit es ist halt
spirituell es hat ja es mit glauben zu
tun aber auch so ein bisschen
oft heißt es ja die die religion gibt
dir das dann vor und du musst das machen
weil du bist ja muslimen und deswegen
musst du jetzt ramadan machen aber das
hat ja für dich ja bestimmt auch so eine
bedeutung also was was bedeutet das dann
für dich das auch machen zu dürfen dass
also wie gesagt von mir ich weiß nicht
wie du dass dies habe sein für mich ist
es wirklich dieser monat wo ich wirklich
einen reset mache mit meinem mindset mit
meinem körper einfach mal wieder andere
strukturen in meinen alltag bringen also
soll ich das geld also ich feiere das
man folglich sind die zeiten bevor ja
ich muss als letztes jahr aber das ist
eine katastrophe wirklich katastrophe
weil man hat ja irgendjemand mal
besuchen können aber das ist jetzt egal
da gab es in kontakt beschränkungen
glaube ich ich glaube da durfte man
manchmal ab 22 uhr raus oder somit das
war schon schlimm muss ich sein ramadan
ist auch viel mit familie zusammen
kommen jeden abend natürlich nicht in
der woche vielleicht weil man hat
vielleicht doch kinder oder muss am
nächsten tag wieder arbeiten sie an das
war ich habe ja quasi für eine
großfamilie wir sind quasi nur mama papa
und an die kinder er habe ich es nicht
keine cousins cousinen aber es ist
trotzdem was andere sondern sieben
geschwister hat und dann jeder lebt dann
irgendwie die tag eine freude sondern
das ist schon echt schön war die zeit
war nicht einsam muss ich sagen und
leute die jetzt zum beispiel es gibt ja
auch leute die sind vielleicht einsam es
gibt ja auch konvertierte leute oder
muslim ab und dann ist es auch so dass
an ramadan wieso visumpflicht für jeden
dass man sagt okay wird über man lebt
auch jemand einen der alleine ist weil
da sollte echt niemand alleine bleiben
gerade seine kundenzahl sollte man auf
jeden fall zusammen verbringt für hansa
ich drück dir das mal in die hand was
die hände
also die gern haben wir jetzt quasi
entkernt und dann kann auch direkt gegen
checken ist ein naturprodukt ob da auch
alles supi ist aber das ist in der regel
so und dann nimmt man sich einfach
gehabt nützlicher bch solus gerne
genommen haben
und dann befüllte die quasi mit eurer
lieblings krippe ich nämlich zum
beispiel spekulation und nicht zu viel
weil wir wollen die daten ja noch
verschließen
so
und jetzt haben wir einfach einmal hier
so rein steckt mir das einfacher
schritt damit dass ich aufgeben
nur damit du das jetzt hier und
das ist man jetzt so so möchte die
mozzarella dieser käse und tomaten
könnten das ist echt wie soll das in
pralinen in meinen augen das ist einfach
glaube und ruhr zu sein ich hätte ja
genau das dann gut abtropfen lassen
gut abtropfen lassen und gern auch hier
das unternehmen soll das ist irgendwo
unterseite das sieht keiner und dann
könnt ihr das entweder hier auf die
matte oder auf backpapier
angefressen ich schlimmeres
und dann könnt ihr immer einen hinweis
oben drauf machen was in drin ist durch
spekulation stream würde ich spekuliere
darüber brüten genau wie kokons beim
kokosraspeln und bei genau haselnuss
creme
kurzbericht hoffe ich würde direkt
wieder
mit der gabel am besten so und jetzt
drauf und das noch sehr spekulativ ist
drin und
was ich so einfach also darüber bröseln
vollprofis
ramadan ramadan ist die schönste zeit
des jahres märz ist das ja ist es
wirklich auch so dass ich schütze zeit
des jahres und das ist die schönste zeit
des jahres muss jetzt jeder muslime dann
fassten oder bist du bist du dann kein
richter muslimen es nicht also es gehört
also es um daten es bis dann verstetigt
sich zu sehr ausschweifendes leistung
vom islam zu viel reden aber es gibt
fünf säulen und die muss man quasi als
muslim erfüllen das bekenntnis
das fasten das spenden die reise dann
nach mekka und das bild natürlich quasi
das ist eine der fünf säulen des islam
also es ist quasi immens wie ich das was
macht es ist mal ist man tritt nicht aus
dem islam browsers nicht macht aber
genau es gibt in jeder religion
pflichten und das ist eben eine des
islam und manche nehmen das natürlich
ernst war und andere wiederum weniger
das heißt bei euch fast noch wann oder
wie ist das dann so also in meiner
familie ich habe auch verwandte die
nicht passten ich faste auch nicht seid
also ich faste auch erst seit ich 20
schüsse das soziale umfeld und bei
hermes familie ist es so da ist es schon
gibt es damit groß geworden bin war ich
kann nichts anderes deswegen bist du
auch so übertrieben diszipliniert in den
ersten jahren ich weiß noch weil ich bin
auch so nicht wenn ich bin ich wirklich
wollte wirklich auch ich hab natürlich
nicht macht aber es ist schon verdammt
anstrengend wenn man das nicht gewohnt
ist er sein leben lang aber wenn man da
aber auch muss aber auch sagen erzählen
hier aber dass auch nochmal
anstrengender weil dann war es mit 1 2 0
2 2 war sonja es ist schon heftig also
gerade warm im hochsommer das war dass
das war wirklich anstrengend da sei es
auch versteht gigawatt gesagt aber auch
mit der mit der zeit ist jamaika also im
winter können wir quasi schon 16 30-17
uhr in japan geht die sonne unter den
effekt und die geht auch sehr spät auf
das heißt man darf quasi ab 7 uhr dann
nichts mehr essen das geht ja auch noch
dann genau aber heute wo man halt jetzt
um 4 uhr diese zehn elf tage also jedes
jahr verschiebt sich das um 10 11 tage
und deswegen gibt es dann irgendwann
ramadan und weihnachten zum gleichen
zeitpunkt gibt es wirklich bekommt
irgendwann in den nächsten
doch genau dem takt kommen also falls
dann haben wir genau dann aufhört machte
sie es dann eigentlich jetzt wenn er
selbst das ja mit familie die macht
jemals zweck aber er machte das jetzt
werden euch freunde jetzt besuchen
werden ramadan ist und ihr es nicht also
müssen die das dann auch an sagte er da
ist zuerst mir nur jeweils weil es ja
ramadan oder nähe ist es überhaupt nicht
so wir haben auch während ramadan kommt
auch manchmal menschen vorbei dir nicht
fassen den bietet kaffee an und auch mal
gucken weil ich wenn ich den kuchen
gebacken habt aber die die frage davos
ist kann ich es
alleine auf social media
machen geschieht ich mache mir leute
wissen dieser geschmeckt hat es
überhaupt nicht schlimm und da geht
jeder ganzen welt machen ja und wenn wir
jetzt jemand einlade jetzt nicht fastet
zum abendessen zwölfter ist quasi das
ist auch so dass von mir das kann eine
halbe stelle was trinken vor meiner nase
ist ja auch egal ja aber die meisten
nicht nennen wir es ruhig
auch mal grenzen und er dreht ja oder
du kommst dann auch trotzdem ganz oft
also wie macht ihr das drehteam flog ich
weiß ich muss ich muss aber auch sagen
sie waren noch nie so früh mit dem drama
dieses drama sie haben echt viel
vorgedreht das ist nicht legal das ist
echt sei trotzdem papst gehen raus
allerdings das nimmt auch echt viel zeit
gerade brauche da ist es war schön im
hahn zudrehen weil man kann auch schnell
agieren und sagt okay das wollte gerade
habe ich mach das jetzt für euch jetzt
wird das man ja auch öfter scheint aber
es sind echt viel zeit im ramadan zu
drehen muss ich sagen weil du willst es
ja auch das was du machst wird sie auch
essen gerade dann ja und etwas
herzhaftes ist dann musst du ganz spät
drehen also dann fangen wir erst um 18
uhr zu sehen sodann wird es klar sagen
wo macht und fertig sein und dann war
die meisten punkte fertig aber da müsst
ihr noch mal die ist das video auf dass
ich diese chance machen da müssen wir
beim test machen ich war halt nicht so
schön wo ich sagen ja das war echt
stressig war lustig aber war nicht schön
ja das war wirklich stress der ja man
konnte das nicht so deswegen ich bin
dankbar so wären wir wirklich an seit er
fünf jahre lang alleine gedreht er
unterstützung von sarah und zum ersten
mal gemacht doch
jochen reich ja genau misst wir bezahlen
mit kuchen und eis ist zum ersten mal
hier vorbereitet dann kannst du schon
mal
ich hab jetzt gesehen mein fokus ist
alles sei es so ich bin ja so richtig
machst du kokosnüsse richtig begrüßt die
spekulation auf jeden fall braucht
hinauswollte wir sind zum ersten mal so
mega organisiert das ist werden dann wir
werden dann über die hälfte vor gedreht
haben mit testers ich bin auch kein fan
davon letztlich reifte gehen während
ramadan online so zu tun als würde man
sich probiert mein gott es ist ja noch
kein ramadan erkennt uns ihr wisst dass
ihr videos vorträgt und einige werden
aber auch im ramadan passieren da wird
dann
aber so hast du bist im ausland soll so
bist du was so insider tipps zu machen
ja endlich mal so entspannend und nicht
das mit was braucht ein bisschen ich
muss schon sagen das ist schon krass
pensum während der ramadan reihe werden
alle zwei tage ein video hochladen am
anfang geht sogar jeden tag also samstag
und wird zwei tage ist das erstellen und
es ist ja auch für euch eine inspiration
ney könnt euch auch in den letzten
jahren auch um gucken was ich alles
hochgeladen habe da geht's wer er
wirklich so in richtung orient also dann
machen wir so diese typische
orientalischen rezepte einen monat lang
und danach geht auch wieder weiter mit
den normalen regierung gab es aber auch
also gerade ramadan finde ich schon so
sehr habe ich anfang ja extra diesmal
die extra so weil das ist ein thema wo
ich finde auch über ich finde auch so
habe schritte sind auch gar nicht so
krass city vertreten
auf jeden fall einer der wenigen
deutschsprachigen raum auf jeden fall
dass auch wirklich gut umsetzt sachen
bedingungen
das geht nicht aber so von der qualität
und stil ist schon cool ist ja einfach
erklärt dass man wichtigsten freue mich
dass jemand so allergien hat und da das
ist ja und dann fehlt der hinweis auf
der doppel wieso eigentlich dachte also
hat das bestimmen grund oder schmeckt
dann einfach nur weil sowieso weil wir
die verkaufen also so dass es echt so
fährt traditionell ist sein fast mit
einer decke zu brechen man sagt auch man
soll eine ungerade zahl an datteln
hessen das heißt so viel in den abend
über ist man dann eine dateien oder drei
oder fünf oder 70 ich denke bei manchen
sachen so ok das klingt schon sehr ruhig
aber irgendwann in den nächsten jahren
denke ich mir kommt wieder irgend studie
die belegt warum eine ungerade zahl an
daten so sinnvoll ist das klingt
wirklich super wert aber es ist es wird
also nachgesagt hat deshalb die weißen
sofa ein lieferant also quasi schon
nicht ein super-job sie sagen aber man
merkt ja auch leute sagen ja ja es ist
mir dass er mich sieht das doppel bälle
satelliten und so das ist ja gerade vor
seinem trip und aus dem einen grund war
dass er halt sehr schnell energie
liefert nicht jetzt gesagt nicht
gesondert zu viel ist auch nicht gut
aber du hast halt im verkehrsministerium
circa 1 person zu treffen wird übrigens
voller vitamine also voller guter
nährstoffe das ist einfach
und lange gefasst hat dann brauchst du
genau sowas damit du schnell energie
liefert energie bekommst du quasi direkt
wieder okay ich mir da genau was ich
sagen muss auch selbst zum star all das
ist das sogenannte frühstück sarah geht
denn wenn ihr wenn die sonne dann wieder
aufgeht dann darfst dann nicht mehr
essen und davor macht das ganz oft so
ich habe dafür neben meinem bett stehen
der mir den wecker sondern genau darin
rheinwasser hinterher und das hält
wirklich satt dann brauchen wir gar
nicht mehr dieses krasse vollwertige
frühstück und ganz traditionell bricht
man halt sein fast mit einer dattel und
ist halt eine suppe dazu um den magen
quasi fortzuschreiben ist sofort rein zu
machen und sollten nicht so ist deftiges
wissen das heißt sie hat jeden tag da
ist
genau das ist ja fast
auf dem kahlen das bringt doch gerade
fünf noch keiner sagen aber viele jahre
hast aber es ist ja auch manche machen
das auch wirklich so leider echt jeden
tag also wie man kocht ja meistens dann
bricht es sei ja da ist es für die
überlegung gestern das ist dann wird man
dass frauen oder dann ist man das hat
nix tag wieder besser skandia im
endeffekt ist es sowieso mittagessen das
ist das ist wirklich ein mittagessen
aber verschoben auf die später aber auch
ein bisschen schöner auch es ist ja auch
traditionelle gerade weil es gerade so
einem ort ist so ja dann versucht man
schon diesen monat ein bisschen schöner
aufzutischen und bisschen mehr auswahl
zu geben gerade war erfasst und sagte
serry eigentlich sagen weil ich mit
veganer zone und ich kann kein
vielleicht ist aber du hast du
wenigstens du hast du aushalten hast du
halt oder halb ich bin ich wirklich froh
darüber wenn jetzt darf ich das nicht
okay dann ist ich lieber etwas anders da
münchen stolpert auf bezogen wenn man
eingeladen ist aber dann und dann ist
wirklich so da will man ja auch irgendwo
die gäste beeindrucken und torwart genau
viel so von von allem etwas aber wenn
sie wird zum beispiel alleine das fasten
brechen dann geht's für uns ein ganz
normales mittagessen mit einer suppe mit
einem salat mit doppeljobs meisters und
genau eine frische suppen erreiche so
viele vitamine drin sind die braucht der
körper und es ist wirklich es zu einem
mythos dass die leute sagen wann stoppt
angeblich war es gibt es gibt leute und
vermiete ich weiß es ja ich weiß nicht
wann umfeld dass es manche die betreiber
einfach schade hatte neulich in seinem
letzten video hurt baklava glaub ich
gegessen so dekadent endlich eigentlich
nur ein ramadan gesehen kam ich wieder
auf die
jeden tag
man muss sich vorstellen muss sich
vorstellt ramadan ist jeder tag samstag
ja genau also man mit zelebriert das hat
natürlich so ein bisschen mehr er ist
ist der euch dann auch so richtig voll
oder heißt es dann sicher nähe sodass
man hat es oder denkt ihr dann so gott
ich muss jetzt allerdings noch
durchhalten also ich glaube die ersten
tage wird man schon viel essen das ist
auch wirklich so das mache ich auch
selber
kommen auf den menschen an ich aber ich
sage also 18 12 30 tagen das ist der
markt kleiner geworden dann kannst du
gar nicht so viel essen und das auch in
anderen kalorienbedarf als ich also ist
vollkommen okay dass du anfangs mehr ist
um die stadt zu halten als ich jetzt zum
beispiel dass auch dafür gibt es eine
richtlinie man sagt immer ein drittel
des mannes soll gefüllt werden mit dem
essen was man sobald ein drittel mit
wasser und das letzte drittel soll er
bleiben und wenn ihr nach dieser
richtlinie fahrt ganz ramadan über dann
habt ihr absolut keine probleme soll es
leer bleiben weil es falls man falls man
da wirklich eingeladen wir zum essen
oder jemanden irgendwas anbieten könnte
da sein aber nicht unverschämt sagt dann
hab ich mir nicht warum ist das aber
auch dann so dass ihr erstmal
sonnenuntergang bzw nachts ist und heißt
das dann wirklich schluss komplett
dunkel sein draußen darf wenn die sonne
anfängt unterzugehen also und warum da
gibt es halt so eine bestimmte uhrzeit
die man quasi nachdem das wird er vorher
verrichten rechnen weil dann quasi einem
zeitpunkt wenn die wirklich der die
sonne quasi auf halbmast mein heck ist
dann ist es meistens schon so okay das
ist jetzt und reger man kabarettisten
aber dann gibt's halt bestimmte uhrzeit
ist noch einmal ein kalender ab
innerhalb der die man sich quasi so
ausdrücken kann der vermieter holen kann
also quasi teilweise in moscheen bekommt
und damit geht man quasi dafür nennt man
dann quasi diese ramadan beginnt die
frage warum das so ist es geht es schon
sehr indirekt ja es geht ja schon es
geht darum wer sobald ein strahl die
erste strahlung der sonne kommt am
morgen heißt es vorbei so das ist schon
diese morgen der wahl gesagt hätte ich
sonnenaufgang sollen auch wenn wir die
kreise gerade oben ist oder wenn die
gerade hoch geht sondern schon diese
erste streich schon so okay da kannst du
mit bloßem auge sehen dass wir richtung
das heißt du hast jetzt nicht ein also
es hat sich unbedingt einen gläubigen
hintergrund warum es jetzt nur seiner
fans sollen nicht da ist und das war
wahrscheinlich früher damit jeder weiß
wann also erst dann richtig was auch
gefragt wurde ist bezüglich eures
schwarzkümmelöl wann sollte man das dann
in der fastenzeit nehmen also dürftest
du das jetzt auch während dem fasten dem
oder er dann zu der fasten brecht zeit
also während des fastens fällt ja welt
man darf weder rauchen noch trinken noch
medikamente zu sich nehmen wenn ihr
medikament solchen dürfte sowieso nicht
fasten bei mir ist es so ich bin mir
auch medikamente nehmen schilddrüsen
tabletten und ich nehme ja auch jeden
tag schwarzkümmelöl genauso die haben
wir machen es immer nach dem essen also
ungern auf mich dann im magen ich finde
man also ist es persönliche präferenz
ich finde man verträgt ich komme damit
klar aber schon du kannst mich dann
merkt aber ich finde also ich mach das
auch immer so ich schon was dann
wirklich nach dem essen nach dem ich
gegessen haben eine halbe stunde später
schlug rein ja ich bin auch ich mal ein
esslöffel nach dem essen jetzt kann noch
mal wegen der schilddrüse da wird
vielleicht noch mal so interessantes
randthema das müssen mit einem arzt
absprechen ich habe mir ebenso geklärt
dass ich mach das ich so mache ich nehme
mein mann musste man eine halbe stunde
vor dem frühstück eigentlich nehmen und
ich mache entweder so dass ich das dass
sich die schilddrüsen tablette einnehmen
wenn das fastenbrechen eintritt erwartet
eine halbe stunde und dann fange ich an
zu essen sind lufthansa habe ich alles
kulig sitzt da mit ihm und schon mal so
ein bisschen suppe oder wenn ich
eingeladen bin und ich dann nicht diese
halbe stunde warten möchte dann quasi
zum skoda also morgens dann quasi das
nicht medaille erstellt genau da habe
ich die danach gibt's porridge oder da
drin und dann macht er jetzt aber
nochmal karton also man sollte ja wir
machen die richtig hunger diese
tabletten das ist unglaublich
bedauerlich frage was sollte man dazu
idealerweise essen beziehungsweise denkt
dachte ich mir jetzt erstmal was ist das
das heißt ihr seid doch erst geht dann
schlafen steht auf frühstück geht weiter
schlafen ging also also bis zum abend
herr wir verbrechen das fasten und
irgendwann geht man ja ins bett muss ob
man darf auch und was man sollte nicht
die nacht zum tag machen viele bleiben
durch gehen was ich finde es ein
bisschen problematisch weil der alltag
geht ja weiter wir arbeiten
wenn man schon mache mir jetzt nicht
plötzlich spielen da sollte man ja schon
so
und so lesen und so was dass es halt
genauso sieht das auch und dann wie
gesagt geht man dann irgendwann ins bett
dann wird sich der wecker gestellt zum
star das ist ja eben dann diese man
kommt ja diese begrenzung wenn die wenn
die sonne aufgeht ist er nicht mehr
essen und dann ist es wichtig sich ganz
ausgewählte sachen zuzuführen also
wirklich nicht anfangen toast brot zu
essen oder wirklich so sachen die
eigentlich lange auf meine richtig
findest du es ja natürlich meine form
nicht mehr also als tipp parat er kommt
wahrscheinlich irgendwie den besten fall
natürlich so haferflocken oder sowas
[Musik]
beide sind frisch aus palästina
angekommen hörte dass viele sich gern
ein decken wir haben noch einiges
darauf hin fall ist es wirklich wichtig
sich dass ich ein frühstück zu machen
dass viele ballaststoffe hat
auch gerne gute kohlenhydrate also das
ist dann quasi bevor die sonne wieder
aufgeht genauer hätte dann wach und
anita schmidt das ist ja dann in vier
uhr morgens irgendwann wenn die mal
schlafen und irgendwann gut wissen
selbstständig da darf der weg auch mal
um 9 uhr 30 klingelt man sollte jetzt
nicht in die bis 13 und 14 uhr
ausschlafen
doch so leute die haben kinderfreunde
hopps gehen raus an die freunde die dann
wirklich so bis 14.50 schlafen damit
jeder gast kann ich ja da ich denke also
es ist nicht beschränkt wie alle glauben
alle eine gewisse super anstrengend
sondern in der sache jetzt zu fasten
dann zu essen und dann geht man raus in
bar und bruchsicher und bisher und dann
geht mir damals futtern seinen weg und
dann sagen okay alles klar fast jetzt in
einer stunde gedacht ich es schon mal
was noch bei mcdonalds oder so und dann
geht man schlafen und dann steht ein bis
fuß das ist normal dieser spruch dass
man aber viele wirklich das ist aber
wirklich leider so lässt sich so auf die
vorbildfunktion machen ich mag es
natürlich nicht aber scheiße doch damit
ja das ist das
drama das ist aber schließt wenn man
sagen du kennt den spruch wasser trinken
und wein predigen oder so
in der art von models ja letzte letzte
frage kommt jetzt hier im endeffekt noch
mal so ein bisschen auch von von vielen
so leben die frage was wolltet ihr schon
immer mal loswerden was habt ihr jetzt
vielleicht noch nicht sagen können
erklären können was euch wichtig ist
weil es ist ja auch so eine sache so
ramadan kannte man ja auch von bayer
noch nicht ist ja vielleicht so fast
schon so ein bisschen eingedeutscht
worden also auch so ein bisschen so es
gibt ja immer so vorurteile was es
vielleicht auch der grund warum jetzt
eben mal das so erklärt und so ein
bisschen näher bringen wollte könnte
auch sagen es sei egal ist ja nicht eure
religion soja also mir war es halt
wichtig weil ich merke auch immer das
während der romanreihe ramadan ist nicht
nur essen und rezepte aber wir sind ein
rezept kanal ich mag es inspiration zu
geben übrigens in das sechste jahr
meiner ramadan reihe und ich merke jedes
jahr das aus der community fragen kommen
warum und wieso habe ich mir gedacht
dieses jahr machen wir so ein kleines
großes faq ohne dabei
religionsunterricht zu machen denn dann
würde das video glaube ich ihre stunden
gehen aber das ist gar nicht unsere
absicht das möchte ich nicht wird er
bleiben immer noch neutral bleiben es
gibt an ostern auch ostern weihnachten
gibt 200 rezepte aber ramadan weil es so
sein ding ist wird der brief ist einfach
ein bisschen mehr als alle anderen feste
sage ich mal das wird von jahr zu jahr
mehr akzeptiert also dann haben wir dann
haben sich und es gibt viel mehr
toleriert das vorjahr das heißt man muss
jetzt nicht alles schlecht reden in
deutschland hiervon etwas müsste dass
rassismus oder sonst was hinein das
immer noch da das ist klar auch
gegenüber vielen gruppen aber ich muss
aber auch sagen ich finde also ich habe
das gefühl dass ich mein empfinden das
ist mehr akzeptiert wurde jetzt nicht
obwohl auch in der politik teilweise ja
durch und auch von den schulen teilweise
ist jetzt einfach mehr toleriert da hast
du vollkommen recht so teilte teil von
ganz grob deutschland geworden richtig
genau hat sich sehr etwas matter auf
instagram teilweise da gibt es diese
instagram filter das ist schon cool auf
jeden fall
da sind schon stolz drauf aber ich bin
auch heute ist das auch dadurch dass wir
eben auch privat und also wir sind halt
wirkt auch kiki und hamza wir zeigen
euch viel von unserem privatleben und
das ist halt nun mal ein ganzer monat wo
er auf instagram vielleicht einfach
einen anderen tagesablauf sehen können
von uns und ich sehe mir das wichtig
dass wir einfach nur noch kurz
aufgreifen da können dass das ganze ist
nicht im zwanziger kam eine freiwillig
meldet sich zum thema gepasst hat ist
haben sie immer so wie er in den stories
baut auf instagram ist sagen euch ja der
ist eben mehr so recht was du das doch
mal das du bist doch ja auch zu wissen
wie hier auch sie läuft sagen ja auch 60
wirklich so nett
wir verabschieden uns ganz wichtig
auf jeden fall
etwas sonne heute wenn es um ihr gebiss
heute freitag es gibt morgen erste
brille also alles um aprilscherze voraus
von der ist kein spaß genau auf jeden
fall worauf ich hinaus wollte ist es
heute die ramadan reihe statt es gibt
morgen ein video grünbaum samstag ist es
gibt sonntag ein video also richtig die
mediale video seine vorgeplant und dann
geht es wirklich los wenn sonntag das
video kommt ab da immer eine zeit wo ich
habe euch gesagt dass diese videos
hervorgetreten schreibt wenig reinhard
song das tut es immer so schön dann
bleibt man auf heute kommt kein video
von kiki nächsten tag noch heute kommen
wir dann wieder alle zwei tage leute
also macht die welt
[Musik]